[Musica]
[Applauso]
vi preoccupate non vi chiederò di
trattenere il fiato per tre minuti 57
però vi chiederò di seguirmi in un mondo
meraviglioso di accompagnarmi in un
lungo viaggio senza respiro in un
elemento che è il primo con il quale
entriamo in contatto quando arriviamo su
questa terra cioè l'acqua ma cominciamo
subito
cosa avete provato quando guardate
questo video che sensazioni sono emerse
cosa avete pensato
paura di non farcela
voglia di respirare
ansia
oppure siete stati pervasi da un senso
di meraviglia misto a disorientamento
quasi come se fosse una vertigine
sapete
penso che
se vi chiedessi di spiegarmi l'apnea con
una sensazione o con una emozione
molto probabilmente la maggior parte di
voi non sarebbe in grado di dare una
spiegazione
però magari c'è qualcuno che penserebbe
che siamo dei matti a fare una roba del
genere quanti pensano che siamo dei
matti per alzata di mano
e quanti no
bene però un po matti siamo
si può trattenere il respiro
per uno spavento oppure per una forte
emozione ma anche per una inaspettata
sorpresa ma si può anche semplicemente
decidere di trattenere il fiato per un
po ed è molto semplice perché possa fare
un lungo e profondo respiro
e poi si parte e si va
ed è così che è successo
la mia prima volta me la voglio
raccontare decisi di partecipare ad un
corso di primo livello la serata
dimostrativa di questo corso
durante la quale furono proiettati dei
video di alcuni atleti che percorrevano
le vasche della piscina sott'acqua
avanti e indietro e uno di questi in
particolare
c'era una ragazza che si immerse quella
sua monopinna
percorse tutta la vasca arrivo al muro
virò la ripercorsa in senso contrario e
così via
voi capite il mio stupore ho detto ma
come è possibile ma quando si può stare
senza senza respirare sott'acqua allora
ho cominciato a contare 1 2 3 5 10 20
50 100
ma com'è possibile
c'è il trucco
e invece no questa ragazza riemerge si
appoggia sul bordo e con un bellissimo
sorriso
dal segno dell'ok e voi capite il mio
stupore sarà bellissima voglio fare
anch'io cosa faccio mi butto non mi
butto e perché a 41 anni suonati e cosa
vuoi fare ora è mica metterti in gioco
un'altra volta non vorrai mica tweak
incominciare un altro sport
la casa famiglia gli amici i gatti e
invece
folgorata sulla via di damasco
mi sono lanciata letteralmente mi sono
buttata in acqua
e nella prova pratica ho provato una
delle sensazioni più belle della mia
vita
sentire l'acqua che scorreva sul mio
viso sulle mani e sulle braccia gli dava
un forte senso di libertà avevo quasi la
sensazione di volare
vedere guardare la striscia blu scorrere
mentre primeggiava lungo la vasca
sembrava quasi di stare su una pista di
decollo ed era come se quella
sospensione
rimuovesse sia fisicamente che
mentalmente
tutto ciò che c'era di terreno
offrendomi la possibilità di osservarli
da un altro punto di vista dall'acqua
appunto e sapete che ho pensato che mi
sarebbe piaciuto tantissimo rimanere là
sotto ancora un po è quanto si può stare
senza respirare sott'acqua perché quello
ormai era diventata la mia ossessione il
mio tormento
siamo degli esseri terrestri e non ce lo
possiamo dimenticare
non possiamo smettere di respirare così
all'improvviso
anzi dobbiamo tenere ben presente che il
respiro è il nostro primo nutrimento lo
facciamo più di 10.000 volte al giorno
eppure possiamo rimanere senza respirare
solo alcuni minuti ma in quei pochi
minuti che avviene la magia perché
l'apnea rallenta la frequenza cardiaca
questo ci permette di rilassarci di
concentrarci sul respiro ci permette di
rilassarci nell'acqua le tensioni si
sciolgono si diluiscono
l'ambiente acquatico
ci costringe a osservarci ad ascoltarci
a sentire i pensieri che vanno e che
vengono a sentire il nostro battito a
sentire il cuore che batte dentro di noi
la vita che pulsa dentro di noi ma
abbiamo un tempo limitato per farlo
l'ambiente acquatico
ci costringe
a cambiare prospettiva ci costringe ad
entrare in un nuovo mondo dentro di noi
ci costringe a osservare le due facce
della stessa medaglia
l'apnea
rallenta la frequenza cardiaca
il fatto che ci rilassiamo
ci porta in uno stato
di che ci permette di godere di
esperienze magnifiche di estremo
benessere estremo senso di unione con
l'acqua e con la vita
partecipo a dare dal 2014
è già nel 2016 partecipavo ai miei primi
campionati del mondo
e mi ricordo che quando il giudice mi
dava il conteggio alla rovescia
mi domandavo ma chi cavolo me l'ha fatto
fare di stare qua ma che cosa sto
facendo ma ma ma ma voglio dimostrare ma
dove voglio andare e posso garantire che
la mia vocina interiore non ha mai
smesso di tormentare la signorina vocina
quella che conosciamo tutti molto bene
e ancora oggi mi domando ma che cavolo
ci sto sempre a fare ai blocchi di
partenza
poi l'ho capito perché è proprio lì che
voglio stare lì in quel preciso momento
perché è come vivere la vita in modo
alternativo
e vedi
da un altro punto di vista e tutte le
volte diventa molto più semplice è tutto
molto più chiaro
l'apnea
smorza i tuoi sensi
tutto intorno a te e ovattato e scopri
molto semplicemente che l'unica persona
responsabile del tuo stato sei tu e sei
costretto a vivere intensamente con la
massima intensità ogni movimento che il
tuo corpo sta compiendo è come una
vertigine un misto tra ebbrezza
il senso del pericolo così attraente da
non riuscire a resistere
e mentre i secondi scorrono
e il senso di annebbiamento si fa più
intenso se da una parte si è concentrati
su come eseguire il gesto tecnico e
quindi si è tranquilli perché aggrappati
a qualcosa di terreno
dall'altra parte vi posso garantire che
si è terrorizzati perché si sta
navigando in un mondo nuovo
la contrazione del diaframma
che col passare dei minuti e dei secondi
diventa molto fastidiosa
può
diventare con il tempo un disagio
accettare e tollerare quel disagio
invece che tornare indietro tutte le
volte che si sente quel fastidio o
tornare indietro tutte le volte che si
sente la voglia di respirare che si fa
più intensa ci rende molto più
controllati e molto più presenti
nella nostra vita e anche nella vita di
tutti i giorni abbiamo a che fare spesso
con il disagio pensateci
incontri imbarazzanti lunghe file
sforzi fisici
litigi discussioni e avere la capacità
di poterli gestire e di poterli superare
non ha prezzo
alla fine
è un po un modo per allontanarsi dalla
superficie
e osservare il mondo da un altro punto
di vista
allontanarsi dalla superficie piena di
rumori di caos di stress
i bui
qual è il vostro modo personale di
allontanarvi dal caos
io ho scelto di non respirare
stare con il fiato sospeso per tenere la
nostra vita sospesa
grazie
[Applauso]